IMMIGRATION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SERVICE.
THIS COMES ON THE DAY THAT
CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON THE HOUSE
SIDE HAS DECIDED TO ASK FOR
DOCUMENTS FROM 81 PEOPLE,
ENTITIES, AND AGENCIES WITH ANY
POSSIBLE LINK TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND REALLY TRYING TO PICK APART
HIS FINANCES AND HIS PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS A LOT.
81 ENTITIES.
MURRAY, IS THIS OVER-THE-TOP?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Dana: EXPLAIN YOURSELF.
>> JERRY NADLER PUT A LIST
TOGETHER.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A PURPOSE
BEHIND THE ENTITIES AND PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE ROLE OF OVERSIGHT.
>> Dana: 81?
>> Marie: I WORKED IN AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS REQUESTED AND
SUBPOENAED.
THAT'S HOW OVERSIGHT WORKS.
IF THERE'S NO PROBLEM, THEY WILL
SUBMIT THE DOCUMENTS AND
EVERYTHING WILL CONTINUE BUT
THEY ARE LOOKING TO ANSWER REAL
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE ARISEN
THROUGH SEVERAL YEARS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH ABOUT EVERYTHING FROM TIES
TO RUSSIA TO WHETHER
DONALD TRUMP PAID OFF STORMY
DANIELS.
WE HAVE PROOF THAT HE DID WHILE
IN OFFICE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THEY
HAVEN'T TOLD THE TRUTH.
>> Dana: IF WE HAVE THOSE
ANSWERS, WHY DRAG THESE PEOPLE
THROUGH IT AGAIN.
>> Jesse: ITS POLITICAL
WARFARE.
STEVE BANNON SAID IT BEST.
DO YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO GIVE UP PEACEFULLY?
IT'S GOING TO BE STREET FIGHTING
UNTIL THE DAY HE'S OUT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
THEY ARE GOING TO USE EVERYTHING
IN THEIR ARSENAL.
I HEARD THAT THEY SUBPOENAED THE
CHEF THAT MAKES THE TACO BOWLS
AT TRUMP TOWER.
IVANKA IS GETTING SUBPOENAED?
>> Dana: SHE IS NOT ON THE
LIST.
>> Jesse: DON JR.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DON JR. IN A
HEARING?
THE BROADCAST NETWORKS ARE GOING
TO TAKE BACK.
IT'S GOING TO MEET AMAZING PIECE
OF TELEVISION AND IN THE END, I
DON'T SEE HOW THE DEMOCRATS LOOK
GOOD.
IT'S REVENGE POLITICS BECAUSE
HILLARY LOST.
THE ONLY THING TRUMP OBSTRUCTED
WITH HILLARY GETTING INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE A GAVEL AND THEY STARTED
ISSUING SUBPOENAS AND DO YOU
KNOW WHAT OBAMA OFFICIALS DID?
THEY GOT CENSURED.
THEY SHREDDED DOCUMENTS.
THEY RETIRED.
THEY LIED.
THEY TOOK THE FIFTH.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE MEDIA DID?
THEY SAID YOU ARE OVERREACHING.
BUT THEN WHEN THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
THE GAVEL, THEY ARE BLOODTHIRST
BLOODTHIRSTY.
>> Dana: WE HAVE LESS THAN A
MINUTE LEFT.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS, GREG.
TOO MUCH?
>> Greg: YOU CAN TELL, EVEN
LOVELY MARIE IS REVEALING A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH GLEE IN THIS
AND I ALWAYS SUSPECT THAT THE
GLEBE REVEALS AN OVER OVERREACH.
YOU ARE ENJOYING IT TOO MUCH AND
THAT THIS WILL NEVER END.
ONE INVESTIGATION WILL LEAD TO
ANOTHER.
ALL THESE ACTIONS AND
INVESTIGATIONS ARE TO DEADEN THE
PAIN OF 2016.
THEY KEEP TRYING TO FIND A
DIFFERENT DRUG AND NONE OF THESE
DRUGS ARE WORKING.
FIRST THE DRUG WAS COLLUSION.
THEN THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THEN YOU HAD COVINGTON.
THAT WAS A DRUG.
KAVANAUGH WAS A DRUG.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT WAS A DRUG.
THE OTHER BOMBSHELLS.
NONE OF THESE STREET DRUGS ARE
TAKING AWAY THE PAIN OF 2016 SO
THEY CAN'T STOP.
>> Dana: AM DAGEN, QUICK WORD.
>> Dagen: DESPERATION TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING TO
COME OUT OF THE MUELLER REPORT
AND I'VE SAID THIS FOR MONTHS.
THEIR FOCUS IS IN EMBARRASSING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ANYONE WHO'S
BEEN CLOSE TO HIM OR WORKED WITH
HIM.
THEY ARE USING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY THAT
NOBODY READ AS A ROAD MAP.
THEY JUST WANT TO EMBARRASS HIM.
>> Greg: I THINK I MIGHT RUN
FOR PRESIDENT BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE 80 FRIENDS.